just two days until King Charles's
coronation lots of folks already mulling
around here Buckingham Palace as a
matter of fact Lionel Richie was here
yesterday and he is fired up for
Sunday's big coronation concert
I mean pinch me somebody this is a once
in a lifetime opportunity so you know to
be a part of it is everything Lionel was
the first Global Ambassador for the
prince's trust what I've heard from
Palace sources they've developed a
really close friendship over the last
couple of years so when he got that
invite for the concert he said yes in
seconds I'm so excited I'm a kid at
Christmas time
thinking of kids we gotta talk about
this five-year-old prince prince Louis
was seen at the rehearsals and is it
safe for him to play a part in this
because we remember Louis here on this
lawn cutting up during the Queen's
Jubilee concert listen Louis is very
young I think the royal family members
are very aware how hard Saturday is
going to be for someone like him it's
likely that he may be removed from the
ceremony itself or parts of it just
because it's a long time to be sat down
but this is the news that will not sit
well with Megan and Harry Prince Harry
will be at the back of the church
basically he's just going to be a
bystander with a nice wooden seat it'll
be interesting to see when they walk
down the aisle whether Harry bows to his
father and to the queen who has not had
many kind words for she was the villain
she was the third person in the marriage
she needed to rehabilitate her image
a few Royals who are relieved that
Megan's not attending because they just
don't want the spotlight on her the
spotlight is on the star of the show
King Charles we've been warned to bring
our umbrellas for Saturday make sure you
find yourself an umbrella
that means that big flyover over
Buckingham Palace we've got the Royal
Navy the Royal Air Force the Armed
Forces all flying over that balcony
moment where we see all the members of
the family if those storms continue
after the procession it may be canceled
thank you